hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel about how to
survive on the online jungle now if
you're watching this you probably spend
a lot of time watching youtube videos or
maybe instagram stories or twitch live
streams and all of these services have
appeared relatively recently but they've
already overtaken all traditional forms
of media for example youtube already has
a monthly audience of over 1.7 billion
every minute users view almost 700 000
hours of video content
and do you know how many people are
actually creating new content on youtube
over 13 million and only 1 million do it
professionally all day long and actually
earn money on it the remaining 12
million are forced to look for other
ways to earn money and things are even
worse on twitch more than half of the
donations end up in the pockets of just
one percent of the streamers and only
five percent can actually earn more than
one thousand dollars per year on twitch
and there are lots of platforms you can
use to get closer to your creator right
the most obvious ones would be patreon
which gives you exclusive access to
creator content for a fee there's only
fans and that doesn't need explaining
and also maybe you've got kickstarter
too where you can get early access to
unique projects and products but also if
you want to invest in something with
which you have an emotional connection
there are lots of nft marketplaces like
openc axi marketplace and lava labs but
the problem here is that there are still
lots of people who doubt the intrinsic
value of nfts
but now i'm going to tell you about a
new way to support your favorite authors
and not only help them but possibly make
the best investment of your life i'm
talking about social tokens
[Music]
let's say it's 2 a.m and you really
should be asleep but you're watching
youtube falling down some rabbit hole of
hydraulic press channels and two tribal
guys making houses out of mud but you
suddenly stumble across something like
this attention please feel attention as
soon as someone mentions me here's my 10
cents for two senses
who said you stand for me or maybe
something like this
[Music]
what do you reckon these guys have in
common
bloody hell they sing well in fact i'd
probably pay to watch them live the
thing is they don't actually have that
many subscribers at all i mean they
should have way more when we observe
their raw talent if i could i'd invest
not in a company with which i have
little emotional connection but in
creators like these guys i'm sure the
value of my share would increase as time
goes on because their market value
obviously doesn't match up with their
market share let's take a look at
another girl now her name is phoebe i
actually went to school with her and
here's a video that i watched not that
long ago and to be honest i was
absolutely blown away so i had to
include in this video she has one of the
most incredible voices i've ever heard
in my
life it's covered in bright white paper
since i met you five minutes later here
we are but it's different now not
walking down that road i was lost but
now i'm fine and all but 21 subscribers
i mean imagine if you could buy a share
in her voice
could that actually be possible imagine
instead of picking up monetary dividends
along the way you receive exclusive
access to interact with such a creator
you'd be able to motivate them into
producing content and when they finally
sell out madison square garden you can
cash in your chips and use that money to
buy a new guitar a signed picture of
kylie minogue or maybe a nigerian steel
works whatever butt is your toast right
well in this case imagination would be
requisite up until recently i think it's
time to introduce this term of social
token and introduce you to some
practical examples of how this works
[Music]
first let's figure out what these tokens
are when it comes to cryptocurrencies
they are often confused with coins but
the difference is fundamental with coins
everything is simple this is a fully
fledged means of payment right for
example you can buy bitcoin using normal
money and then use it to pay for say
pizza a laptop or even a vpn server
hundreds of thousands of companies
around the world actually accept bitcoin
just like they do for dollars or euros
tokens provide access only to the
products of their creator they're more
like a bus ticket right you can buy a
bus ticket to tour the city but this
ticket cannot be used on the metro or
say a bus in another city and some
tokens can be compared to securities
promissory notes or shares right they
might give the right to receive
dividends from an economic standpoint a
token is a digital asset that you as an
investor buy from the issuer of the
token
tokens can act as a means of payment but
only work within the framework of the
project of their creator from a
technical point of view tokens are an
add-on to existing digital currencies
they don't have their own blockchain and
commissions for transactions within them
are paid in other cryptocurrencies in
essence a token is a kind of smart
contract the creator of the token
determines their number the rules of use
and the initial price but beyond that it
all depends on the market don't beat the
issue of the token may go bankrupt and
then you'll be left with a meaningless
set of numbers on the other hand you can
invest in a project that will bring huge
profits in the future in this way the
tokens are somewhat reminiscent of what
happened in the 18th century with the
continental currency of the us
now they served as a temporary tender
during the revolutionary war and were
backed by nothing other than a promise
from congress to buy them back after the
war ended the first issue in 1775 had
two million dollars worth of them over
the next five years 125 million more
would be printed now at the beginning of
the war one silver dollar was worth a
paper dollar and a quarter five years
later the rate fell to one to one
hundred and sixty-eight
would you invest in such an asset
well i know who thought otherwise
[Music]
timothy dexter a man of 18th century
massachusetts is known for his streak of
fantastic investments despite being
probably the most objectively idiotic
man to have ever existed now dexter left
school to work on a farm at the age of
eight and eventually found work as a
leather tanner seeking out a better life
for himself he moved to the city of
newburyport in his early twenties where
he managed to woo a certain lady
elizabeth frothingham a wealthy 32 year
old widow now they were actually married
within a year and the gold digging
dexter was then granted access to her
savings
and then he did what any other
half-witted lottery winner would do and
spent it but the what on here will amaze
you dexter with no real knowledge of
economics and lots of spare cash
interpreted the mass depreciation right
of the us currency as a bargain sale he
then spent his wife's entire savings on
crates of these heavily depreciated
continental dollars that were only due
to plummet in value in fact by 1781 they
had become so worthless that they
actually ceased to circulate as currency
however shortly after dexter had drained
his wife's account the american
constitution was ratified and this meant
that the new government began offering
treasury bonds in exchange for the old
continental bills
now although these bonds were worth one
percent of the face value of the old
bills dexter had stockpiled these bills
at such a low rate those buybacks began
his stockpile increased in value
exponentially so he eventually sold all
of the bills and became very wealthy
practically overnight you know dexter
provides this kind of microcosm for the
world of investing in the fine words of
matthew mcconaughey nobody knows but
here's the thing when most people think
of investing they think about business
but what if in the ever-growing backdrop
of web 3 you could use social tokens to
invest in people so let's go deeper into
this
tokens can be issued practically by
anyone any company or even ordinary
person and the number of tokens is
limited and known in advance unlike
coins they cannot be mined and their
quantity is completely controlled by the
creator
to do this you don't even have to do any
serious programming and climb into the
wilds of cryptography for this the
creators of the ethereum pro school have
developed a special standard erc20
now you've got a template for describing
the future token the definite functions
issuance rules and transferability
between users social tokens can be
off-chain or on-chain assets that a
brand community or influencer can use to
monetize themselves beyond their typical
means social tokens effectively combine
the positive qualities of different
donation systems with the
decentralization of cryptocurrencies and
wraps them up into it
web 3 dolmado's role for us all to enjoy
and you know tokens can be issued by
ordinary people i'm talking artists
bloggers musicians designers or even
athletes if your abilities are known to
other people if you have viewers or fans
you can issue your social token
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now there are these tokens called
personal tokens and as a rule they can
be exchanged for working time the
results of labor or say the income of
the creator doesn't sound very clear
well look at this this is alex max may
now two years ago he held a human ipo
alex created a personal token to raise
twenty thousand dollars in order to move
to san francisco i'm going to fundraise
twenty thousand dollars
and whoever gives me that money i will
give them fifteen percent of my future
salary in addition token holders got the
opportunity to vote for some of alex's
personal decisions communicate
exclusively with him on social networks
and receive advice in the field of
startups and cryptocurrencies with
personal tokens fans can invest in their
idols many expect that the value of
their tokens will increase with the
popularity of their creators celebrities
can use tokens as a substitute for a fan
club membership card right for example
only owners of personal tokens can
access private broadcasts backstage
content and even chat with the star in a
private chat companies or communities
can also take the place to the creator
here and these are called community
tokens
[Music]
[Applause]
such tokens allow you to truly become
part of the community and this is
fundamentally different from buying a
membership in a prestigious golf club
for instance you cannot transfer the
club card to another person sell it or
bequeath it the community token on your
hand can be sold at any time and if you
correctly guess the potential of the
company with great profit for yourself
community tokens are like luxury real
estate or stocks in the old days they
not only bring profit but also give the
right to access an elite group of people
and companies receive more than just
funding using the system of rules you
can create complex loyalty programs
flexibly manage access to your own
digital assets and even gamify
communication with customers the
creators of the education ecosystem l e
d u have chosen this path they provide
tokens to their learning partners and
add bonuses after completing each lesson
this concept is called learn and earn
and has already gained a lot of fans in
addition it's also quite promising to
use your own tokens in exchange for
unique digital goods especially nft art
or poap badges the essence of such
badges is similar to magnets on your
refrigerator right they show everyone
where you've been and when
so look we've established that social
tokens can be ways of investing in the
success and growth of your favorite
creator while at the same time getting
close to them with exclusive access
rights however social tokens don't have
to be centered around an individual in
fact they can be much more community
focused or even nfc focused
[Music]
in autumn of 2021 this thing sold for
3.4 million us dollars now i won't spend
time on introducing this ridiculously
sought after nft club to you as i'm sure
you're in the know but what is
interesting here is that these are
arguably some of the trendiest most
game-changing nfts to have ever hit the
market but why are we bringing up old
news here well something called apecoin
has just come out with a twist it's
effectively an ethereum based token that
gets its utility from the power that it
gives to the token holders the purpose
of apicoin is to give back to the
community in a brand new decentralized
governance framework
holders of the token will be able to
vote on key decisions like hiring
endeavors partnerships benefits and
investments there's even a board of
directors that oversee the entire
ecosystem
moreover they'll be voted in every year
by the community so apecoin is
fundamentally a social token
now i brought up the bayc here because
this club is at the forefront of all
things trendy and the fact that they're
adopting a social token here is a sure
sign that these are the tokens of the
future nft communities are starting to
realize that the inherent
characteristics of nfts can be somewhat
limiting after all it's difficult for a
community to form around the bartering
system alone right
nfcs are great at creating hype and
scarcity but they're not so great for
the community limited supply and the
lack of free-flowing funds throughout
the community means that the industry is
always looking at new ways of
on-boarding community members and
moreover transferring value to them and
this is very interesting is there's a
real desire for what the social token
can offer moving forward and in my
opinion it's simply a natural evolution
for the industry have i convinced you
that social tokens are a good idea yet
well let's take a look at some of the
platforms that can be used to create a
social token
[Music]
so firstly i stumbled across bitcloud
this seems to be a platform for those
looking to make money it's more about
the trading and mining of tokens and
there doesn't seem to be much of a
community atmosphere here or certainly a
focus my impression is that this is more
for the crypto maniacs and people are
looking to make some hard dosh on the
new social token revolution if that's
you go check it out but it's not where
you'll find bradley just yet next i came
across rally.io and to be honest i was
pretty impressed by this platform as it
does seem to be very creative focused
and it says very explicitly that you
don't need to be a crypto nuts to take
part there's also quite a neat nft
marketplace on the website which i also
like however it turns out that you
actually have to use the rallycoin to
buy a token which while easy to get your
hands on is a real barrier to entry for
those that aren't in crypto if i were to
get a social token i'd want something
purely
purely on the basis that crypto is like
smoking you're either fully involved
socially involved or not at all and if
you're not involved yet it's unlikely
that your mate joe down the pub is going
to convince you to start a wallet in
layman's terms i want both my nan and
raj underscore cryptoexpert66 to be able
to hold my social token right i also
stumbled across roll and this is
tryroll.com to be specific these guys
looked pretty good and i like how they
use the idea of social money as a lot of
people still envision tokens as those
old things you put in the machines in
the metro so you know inclusive i did
actually message these guys but my mate
sent me an article iterating that when
it was launched there was this huge hack
where someone stole about 5.7 million
ethereum from them and they also have an
app i took a look at it but it's not too
user-friendly i wasn't sure on their
current selection of creators either i
don't think it's that large i also came
across superfandom.io which is basically
the complete opposite of big cloud as
far as i'm aware there's no trading at
all it's just experiences with creators
i mean maybe this is good for angel
underscore bcs14 from derbyshire but no
good for bradley
[Music]
the story of the creation of social
tokens sounds extremely tempting but
it'd be mistaken not to discuss the
dangers of this topic in today's video
now first you invest your money without
getting any guarantee of getting it back
creators are not required to buy back
their tokens and only the market
determines the current price in the case
of investing in creative people this is
extremely dangerous for instance if
you're investing in david beckham's legs
right your idol is unlikely to have
something like that i mean the singer
can lose his voice get into drug
problems or simply well leave to look
for himself on the other side of the
world a blogger can get tired of making
videos every day and a designer can get
tired of generating tons of fresh nft
art are you willing to bet money on the
hard work and talent of a stranger and
also the token market is extremely
unregulated even worse so than the
cryptocurrency market there are just too
many grey areas here and the market's
too young for lawyers to prepare all of
the necessary laws rules and regulations
and also the banking system is very
conservative and cautious so don't be
surprised if you can't actually cash out
your social tokens i mean the
transactions can literally be blocked
for money laundering and thirdly there
are risks for the creators of personal
tokens ill-conceived placements service
failures and any other technical
problems can seriously undermine the
credibility in the eyes of the fans be
that as it may i believe that social
tokens will remain in trend for the
coming years this is a risky investment
right now but the potential for their
use has yet to be truly uncovered
in addition it's an ideal means of
payment for a world where people not
only create but also truly own their
content
social tokens represent web3 connecting
creators and consumers without the
unnecessary intermediaries perhaps for
the first time in the history of mankind
artists will no longer be hungry
which of the open sea authors do you
think will become salvador dali of the
21st century right so anyway my name is
bradley this is thumbsup and thanks for
joining us i will see you in the next
video
[Music]